Obesity is officially a disease!!
Now, where's my cupcake?
Hey guys Tara here for Dnews - and if you're
the type of person who's constantly worried
about your weight, then do we have the story
for you!
It's been almost a year now since the American
Medical Association officially classified
obesity as a disease.
One of the hopes behind this was to raise
awareness to the growing problem of obesity,
but new research suggests that the classification
may be doing more harm than good.
A study published in the April issue of Psychological
Science, recruited over 700 participants to
take an online survey related to health and
weight.
They calculated the BMI of every participant
- some obese, and some of average weight - and
then asked them to read one of three articles.
The first article was a standard public-health
message about weight, another was a NYT article
describing obesity as a disease, and the third
was an article specifically stating that obesity
is NOT a disease.
The findings show that obese participants
who read the article classifying obesity as
a disease, placed less importance on health-focused
dieting and reported less concern over their
weight, compared to obese individuals who
read the other two articles.
They also chose higher-calorie food options
when asked to pick a sandwich from a provided
menu.
Meaning the "obesity as a disease" mentality
actually led to unhealthier food choices.
Crystal Hoyt, the researcher who spearheaded
the study, says "the term disease suggests
that bodies, physiology, and genes are malfunctioning.
By invoking physiological explanations for
obesity, the disease label encourages the
perception that weight is unchangeable."
However, they're not disputing the fact that
obesity should be classified as a disease.
Rather, the aim was to understand how public-health
messages can have unintended consequences.
The most interesting aspect of the study,
I think, is that the people who accepted the
disease classification but made unhealthy
choices anyway - reported greater body satisfaction
than any of the other groups.
So they may be unhealthy - but at least they're
happy!
What do you guys think?
Should obesity be classified as a disease?
And does knowing that it is, affect your food
choices?
Let us know in the comments below and for
more episodes of Dnews, subscribe here.